all right we have the ax trash taste
Booth I'm gonna find out which trash
taste fan has the worst anime taste what
is the worst anime of all time there's a
lot out there honestly the worst off the
top of my head one piece of trash
what is the worst anime of all time well
the man already said it
more time
press that one with the cringy girl
you're gonna need to narrow it down man
she has like baggy eyes what's a moto
yeah that one that's the literally the
worst what's the worst anime of all time
personally I didn't care too much about
Jujutsu Kaizen I've heard the manga is
good though but I don't know is your
name Joey in your opinion is the worst
anime of all time Sword Art online and
I've seen it 10 times because I've
showed it to every single person that I
know because it's the worst anime I've
ever seen in my life but it's amazing